hey guys it's Justine and we were back
with the new iPad pro magic keyboard I
did a review talking about all the ways
that I've been using the iPad over the
past month and how the iPad pros magic
keyboard has helped improve what I have
been doing and how excited I was to use
it but after reading the comments there
were so many questions that you guys had
that I did not answer at all that I
honestly didn't even think about
answering because a lot of those ways is
not how I use the iPad so thank you guys
so much for all of your comments
hopefully this video will answer all of
your questions and of course if not
there's still a comment section leave
them there or send me a tweet on Twitter
we now have the white desk back so you
guys can actually get a chance to see
the keyboard the first thought was
saying I didn't talk about any flaws
with this keyboard but for how I was
using it it was perfectly fine first of
all I would see with this especially if
you're someone who does want to write on
your iPad or take a lot of notes in this
position right here it does tend to be a
little bit shaky so if you are doing a
lot of note taking or illustrating I
don't think this is the best orientation
for this but if you are doing a lot of
typing or any other types of things like
that that's where this really does shine
if you do want to take it off it's so
easy you just kind of that's it I'm
ready to illustrate let me just show you
this actual case itself so a lot of
people were wondering if this is strong
yeah I mean it's pretty sturdy so I put
the iPad back on it like it's it's on
there so yes the magnets are pretty
strong
I enjoyed this thread on Twitter and I
thought I would try out this viewing
angle let me see how this works so you
flip this over
okay so hmm it's actually not bad at all
I mean if you want to look ridiculous at
a coffee shop like this is what you
could do like it's actually working
there's like no bounce at all
you guys remember before like this is
what we were dealing with about this I
am so glad that you tweeted me this
because this is incredible this is a
whole new world I feel that the Little
Mermaid know
it's Aladdin yeah disregard this also
keeps those coffee shop workers from
seeing what I'm doing you to get two
more right here I'd be curious for
people who are doing illustration like
what this is like for them
well the iPad just fall if you tilt it
to backwards I don't know well I mean
yeah if you push it over glad I could be
here with a hearted in questions Jeremy
is wondering how Apple handles when the
cursor is idle for a long period of time
I'm moving the cursor can you see that
I'm going to just stop using the cursor
it's right there and it just disappears
and then when I go back to use the
cursor again oh it's right where I left
it I wished everything was like that did
the trackpad it feel similar to the Mac
Pros I mean it does it's a trackpad it's
the same feel it's just much smaller
let's see how big or not big this is a
little under four inches wide with a
diagonal of foreign just a little bit
over four but the feel of it feels just
like a normal track pad like it doesn't
feel different than using a MacBook
spencer's asking if the trackpad clicks
physically or does it vibrate like the
newer Mac books it is a click like an
actual click like I can see the trackpad
moving and it supports a lot of the same
gestures that you're used to on your
MacBook Kris is asking if the bottom
part is strong enough to where you can
pick up the iPad magic keyboard from the
edge near the trackpad with all the case
spending I don't think so he doesn't
know it's not it's very sturdy which
leads me to the weight of this thing I
guess I didn't really think about how
heavy this was said it really compare it
to anything and I'm used to having a
keyboard case on my iPad so it already
is a little bit heavier so this is a
20-18
ipad with the new keyboard on it
definitely much lighter
how much lighter Wow well I'm glad you
asked because I have a scale here for
some reason I thought I was gonna need
to mail out a lot of packages in this
pan down
I wouldn't know how much my package is
laid well guess what I never needed to
do mail any packages or need to know the
weight of them but now we can use it to
weigh my iPad so let's start off by
weighing the case 1.09 all right let's
see how much the other keyboard weighs
0.14
well that's significantly lighter now
let's see what it weighs the whole set
up look at that
30 pounds how much does my macbook weigh
4.7 you see how much the macbook air
weighs two point one four oh so I guess
that does answer the question of yeah
it's it's definitely got some weight to
it
it does feel substantial but carrying it
around it just feels like it just feels
natural like it doesn't feel heavy but
when comparing it to other things like
the smart Keyboard yeah it's definitely
heavier oh it's even taller too check
this out it looks like it's a little
over a half inch taller so this
pass-through charging hinge which is
amazing and I know I mentioned it so
many times I member for you because it's
one of the things that I've been using
so much with it that's what's adding a
lot of our extra height and probably
some of the weight as well so yeah it is
a little bit thicker it is a little
heavier but this is a more premium of a
product even when you're holding this
keyboard up it feels way flimsier but
it's not as it's definitely not as
sturdy that is for baddest for sure that
actually answers another question that
you guys had are the magnets stronger on
this one than the previous keyboard so
yes it definitely is now the question is
if you have a 20-18
ipad is it worth it to do the upgrade to
the 2020 honestly I don't think so if
you already have this 2018 iPad I don't
think there is a huge need to upgrade
this can do everything that you need to
do this has a faster processor it does
have the lidar scanner so if you are
doing a lot in the AR space then maybe
you might want to upgrade but if you
have a perfectly good iPad that honestly
is no reason that you need to upgrade
but you can use both of these keyboards
with your previous gen iPad as you can
see here this is the previous gen from
2018 you'll just have a little cut
where the larger camera is it is nice
that the keyboard is backlit let's do a
comparison of the brightness of this
iPad keyboard compared to the MacBook
here's the keyboard brightness
side-by-side the MacBook in person looks
a little bit brighter but on camera they
kind of look similar and the iPad will
automatically dim if the screen isn't
being touched or active so you notice
when I touched it the brightness on the
keyboard lit back up you can adjust the
brightness with touch controls here on
the MacBook keyboard whereas this is
what you get whatever it decides the
brightness is that's how bright it is
there's no option to change the keyboard
brightness on the magic keyboard I
talked about the pass-through charging
probably forty five million times in my
review because that's what I am most
excited about one of the main questions
I think people were wondering is can you
use this to transfer data much like you
can this board no it's strictly for
charging only does it have balance
issues on a lapsed iPad browsing now
feel laptop class I do actually prefer
browsing the web on an iPad like pinch
to zoom I mean so great as far as a
question about it being stable on your
lap let me go sit some more and put it
on my lap okay well that's gonna slide
off my legs regardless so yoga pants in
a slick surface is not an option as far
as it being on my lap so because this is
like a more of a grippier surface it's
not sliding off of my pants but it is a
little bit top-heavy so it does feel
like it's kind of falling MacBook has a
whole another problem cuz it's sliding
huh so both of them have issues with
laps it could be a pants problem I'm not
sure if I answered your question well I
tried my best
hey Sebastian wants to know the angle of
the keyboard the screen itself though is
adjustable between 90 and 130 so I feel
like that's a pretty good viewing angle
from any type of typing situation for
watching content and if you want to see
how I've been using this there's so many
scenarios that I have in the previous
video that I did so go check that out if
you want to see more about the viewing
angles
and how I've been using this iPad for
the last month the new iPad and keyboard
is a few hundred bucks cheaper than the
new MacBook Air don't you think it's
better to get the air than the iPad and
keyboard and honestly this is something
that I can't answer this is something
that you have to sort of answer for
yourself what are you going to be doing
most this also ties into Jacqueline's
question who is asking if students
entering college are already in college
what will be your recommendation iPad or
a MacBook I almost want to say I think
that you should get a MacBook just
because you don't know what software
you're gonna need for school there's a
lot of unexpectedness I feel like you
could definitely get away with an iPad
depending what your major is so I don't
want to tell you either way what you
should or shouldn't get if I were to
choose over an iPad or a MacBook I
myself would have to get a MacBook
because there's a lot of video editing
software a lot of plugins a lot of
things that I need that computer for
this iPad can't do but could I survive
just with this iPad if that's all I had
yeah I most definitely could let's talk
about the keyboard itself how does it
type it's weird because I didn't really
mention it that much in the review
because it just feels like a normal
MacBook keyboard I said that I didn't
think that I had to elaborate more on it
feels just like the magic keyboard on
the Mac books right now other than the
larger trackpad this keyboard feels
almost identical this has a 1 millimeter
travel distance a both almost even sound
the same I think if you blindfolded me
and just let me touch a few keys I might
not even be able to tell the difference
I mean I might be able to buy them I
also might not be able to so I hope that
there's answered some of your questions
but for me personally most of you were
saying Justine and that seemed to be a
glorified iPad stand for you well yes
that is true but for the way that I've
been using as iPad this has completely
transformed the way that I have been
using it it's been making things way
easier and now having a full keyboard
with the trackpad that makes editing so
much easier I know I've mentioned it so
many times but the pass-through charging
is so key especially if you're doing
things where you need to have access to
this USB C port and also charge at the
same time so that being said I freaking
love this yes it's a little bit
expensive but if this is going to be
something that you are spending a lot of
time with the ease of use the
functionality and this viewing angle I
don't know it's worth it
I was really hoping that would have just
stuck right on there yes don't forget to
subscribe okay bye
[Music]